- your question if I ask you a question
with a let me go on to other things
well that's okay
I'll tell you what I promise y'all
answer your question come on come on
over here well I will do it after this
is over I promise I'll sue
[Applause]
folks look the mr. mayor thanks for the
passport to get into town and marry and
look it's great to be back in Iowa the
fact of the matter is that the good and
bad news for you is that I'm gonna be
here a lot and no one no one is gonna
work harder I know I was criticized by
one of my colleagues and they're all
good people running for the nomination
for not being at the Hall of Fame dinner
this weekend but the Hall of Fame dinner
occurred and I let them know way ahead
of time I wouldn't be there because my
my daughter who's the love of my life
and the life of my loves birthday as
well as my granddaughter Maisy who's an
all-state athlete and graduating from
high school and to me I have to admit to
you
this particular person said he would
have been there well I got different
values said it's family family family my
life I would I know may I make no
apologies and make no apologies for not
showing up and speaking for five minutes
since they got about almost eight months
to be able to come and talk to y'all but
I would not miss my granddaughter's
graduation I think all those either Iowa
values you wouldn't either and so folks
um I I apologize again that of the
conflict and the dates but look it
wasn't planned this way but as we used
to say in the business my friend Donald
Trump president Trump is is in Iowa
today and because and I hope he's
presence here will be a clarifying event
because Iowa farmers have been crushed
by his tariffs or with China and no one
knows better than the folks in Iowa he
thinks of being tough
is great well it's really easy to be
tough when someone else absorbs the pain
farmers manufacturers automobile
industry the fact is he backed off this
threat on terrorists with Mexico lately
because he realized that he was likely
to lose Michigan Ohio in Iowa all of a
sudden he is as we say in southern
Delaware had an altar call he's seen the
Lord and but make no mistake if if in
fact things get tough again he's gonna
start to threaten tariffs again and to
him American workers in my view are just
a pawn their pawns in his game and let's
talk a little bit about China because
China proposes real challenges the
United States and some ways the real
threat to the United States but Donald
Trump is only exacerbating the threat in
the danger but the reason I find myself
optimistic is that I met point I've been
making a long time if we do we need to
do at home if we stand up for American
interest if we invest in our people our
live our values and work with our
partners we can out-compete China every
single solitary day and every other
nation in the world and here's what we
should be doing about China we should be
investing ourselves in research
infrastructure modernize our workforce
so Americans can compete with and win we
should be rallying our friends to take
on China's abusive practices around the
world and I mean our friends in the
region instead of alienating whether
it's South Korea or Japan or any of the
other folks in the region that have been
our allies relative to China improve our
defenses by so companies don't have to
give tech capability to China that they
steal work in a way where we in fact
treat China the way they treat us they
won't let us invest without having in
China without them having a 50%
ownership and still the intellectual
property well they shouldn't invest here
but it's not farmers who should pay that
price it should be we
be treating them the way they treat us
and such but look
you know but I think the president has
made the wrong choices almost all along
a line the devastating flooding here and
an Iowa overall and throughout the
region yet President Trump denies there
was any such thing as climate change and
and it'd be funny if it weren't so so
damaging and so serious and what about
health care trying to have the Justice
Department declare the Affordable Care
Act unconstitutional and he saw how well
trying to take away people's health care
worked in 2018 and are off your
elections did you find a Republican
inside for health care I didn't find one
and yet they were trying like the devil
to eliminate the Affordable Care Act how
do you deal with your child who has a
pre-existing condition and you can't
afford the insurance how do you keep
your child on your health care policy
for their 26 if they are struggling to
find work how do you deal with all the
things that affect our the entire health
care system you're a a nice town here on
a ton of 25,000 people you continue to
eliminate Medicaid and they want to cut
Medicare as well how long are you gonna
be able to maintain your community
hospitals here how long is that going to
last
so folks look you know President Trump
thinks that Wall Street and super-rich
built this country they didn't build the
country the middle class built this
country and unions built the middle
class that's how we got to where we are
folks
[Applause]
folks we gotta build an economy the
rewards work not just wealth we got to
return the dignity of work of work you
know the and I think that look I believe
that the president is literally an
existential threat to America for three
reasons one he is a genuine threat to
our our core values and if you wondered
about that remember what happened in
Charlottesville I never thought I'd see
that happen in my lifetime again you had
people come climbing out of the fields
and under rocks carrying torches
contorted faces chanting the same
anti-semitic vile that was chanted in
Europe and in Germany in the 30s
same exact language carrying carrying
Nazi flags accompanied by white
supremacists accompanied by the Ku Klux
Klan and confronted by decent people who
said not in my city and what happened
when he was asked to comment and he said
quote there were very fine people in
both groups
no President United States Democrat a
Republican has ever ever ever said
something like that never and it was a
response heard round the world round the
world but most importantly as the
response heard by our children our
children are listening the idea that we
give credit look folks America was built
in the way we were built basic core
values decency honor leaving no one
behind realizing that there are things
that are bigger than you in America that
we have to get together we have to
cooperate but this is a guy who does
everything to separate and frighten
people it's about fear and loathing it's
about what he can weigh he calls people
the names he calls them no president has
done something like that for God's sake
I mean it's bizarre and it's damaging
and so I think he's genuinely a threat
to our core values and he's a threat to
our standing in the world on the d-day
ceremonies the d-day ceremonies it was
astounding to me that he was tweeting
attacks on everybody from the mayor of
London to Bette Midler he found time to
go after Bette Midler for God's sake in
the middle of the D Day ceremonies for
real not a joke and and instead of
repairing the relationships with our
allies he's continued to damage them you
know think about this
no president on estates is ever ever
ever since the end of World War two we
built that Atlantic Alliance and NATO
ever threatened to leave NATO never got
after our allies embracing dictators and
thugs from Putin to Kim jong-un calling
them my friends sending lovely while
he's sticking his poking his finger in
the eye of our allies what's going on
here this is really dangerous stuff and
it's not easy he's a threat in my view a
threat to our core values and folks the
fact of the matter is that four years of
Donald Trump will be viewed as an
aberration in American history eight
years eight years will fundamentally
change who we are as a nation and how
were viewed around the world we're not
only the most powerful nation in the
world we've led America we've led the
world not by the example of our power
alone but by the power of our example
that's why the rest of the world has
followed us because of our values who we
are who we say we are decency honor and
it is being absolutely thrashed around
the world and look the idea that I
believe and I didn't believe this if you
had asked me this five years ago I told
you you're crazy I think there's a
genuine threat to American democracy
you know I recommend the book to you by
two professors Harvard's how democracies
die none of them died by in the last ten
of years by someone battering down the
door of the President or the
yes they won a general election then
they brought down all the barriers that
prevented the abuse of power they
brought down all those things that
allowed us to be a nation that we were
together allowing us to work in a way
that we had arrived at a consensus it's
always been about the abuse of power and
look what he's doing
he not only attacks courts because he
said how can a judge with Mexican
ancestry treat me fairly
the the the news media all them back
there
they're all fake news he says hello
everybody thinks that's kind of you know
it doesn't mean much but look at the
people copying his ways all around him
on the world whether it's or bond and
hungry whether it's in the Philippines
there are thugs all over the world using
the same kinds of language she's using
now and what what are we saying to the
world what are we saying to the world
and folks you know the goal is simple
when he discredits the news discredit
the Free Press he gets to run roughshod
over the country by the way as you've
noticed press isn't always that great
with me I'm not that crazy about him
sometimes do what they write
but they are the Fourth Estate as
Jefferson said if I have to choose
paraphrasing them one of the three
branches of the governor of Free Press I
picked the Free Press folks the fact of
the matter is
[Applause]
we're at a moment where I think we have
to reinstate our constitutional norms of
the country the presidency is not
without limits it's not without limits
it's a co-equal branch of the government
with the Senate the house the Congress
as well as as well as with the courts
and folks I'm not naive you know some
say that this is an old-fashioned way of
doing things well if it's old-fashioned
way of doing things we're in real
trouble man we're real trouble if the
idea that the very thing that hell's
most heterogeneous nation democracy in
history the world together as it has now
for us is old-fashioned then I ask you
how did we last for all these years and
grow as the verses we are because of
these documents that we say we believe
we hold these truths elf evident but all
men and women are created equal we the
people no other no other country in the
world is unique as America we're unique
in all of history
because of the nature of who we are in
the system we created to engage everyone
and this being ripped look I don't think
it's naive I don't think it's
old-fashioned way of doing things that
says the system has to be restored you
know - I think it's time - you know he
says let's make America great again
let's make America America again
the coach
look there's a lot there's a lot going
on
just take the obvious but
notwithstanding all the problems we have
I am genuinely optimistic when the
American people have been given a chance
they've never ever ever let the country
down for real we not only have the most
powerful military in the history of the
world as I said we rule not by an
example of our Papa the poverty they
believe the rest of the world we're in a
situation where in the United States
America we have more great research
university and Iowa - coast-to-coast
than all the rest of the world combined
and every single major innovative thing
has come out of a research university
it's been monetized by corporations but
it's because of the brilliance you own
those research universities the American
people own them and it's time we began
to realize who we are we're walking
around with our heads down like woe is
me what's the matter with us this is the
United States of America there's not a
thing we've ever said our mind to that
we haven't been able to do together not
a joke never never never never
but we're walking around like woe is me
there's not another country in the world
if we do what we have the capacity of
doing they can touch us it can touch us
and the rest of the world needs us as
well we are the indispensable nation
because who else fills that vacuum but
us everything of our economic growth to
our national security state there's not
a thing we can't do and all the things I
talk about whether it's my my plan
relative to the environment or health
care or education folks we can afford it
you know why we can afford it without
raising your taxes I tell you why how
many you really did really well with
that with that Trump tax cut raise your
hand man you know what happened in
addition to that you know how many you
know how many tax loopholes are now in
the law when Reagan was president
there were 800 billion dollars for the
tax loopholes there are now a trillion
four hundred six hundred and forty
billion dollars in loopholes you can't
find me an economist at any university
in this state or anywhere in the United
States America that can justify the last
six five to six hundred billion of those
those those tax cuts why should you get
a break for racehorses does not get
break for child care
you know if I'm serious we don't have to
punish anybody for example for example
we can put every single solitary
qualified student in Community College
as one example for free well there goes
that big spending Biden okay
typical Democrat man he's out spending
my money gonna raise my tack you can do
it with one thing just eliminate 17
billion of the one trillion six hundred
billion plus dollars you know what's
called thing called stepped-up basis I
didn't know what it was because when I
was a senator when I I was listed as the
poorest man in Congress that's what
happens you get lit and buy still I got
a good salary as a congressman but it is
one of those deals where you know when
you get elected to twenty nine that's
what happens you know well here's the
deal the fact of the matter is
stepped-up basis means if you go up
making a capital gain you buy stock and
it's worth a hundred thousand and you
make hundred fifty thousand or a million
you make so on well guess what you pay a
capital gains tax on that well the tax
is much lower than your normal tax that
means the government in fact collects
seventeen billion less dollars in taxes
because of that particular exemption in
the code if you eliminate that one you'd
raise seventeen billion dollars out of
one trillion six hundred plus billion
dollars you would hurt nobody
it's not gonna change anybody standard
of living now what what is it it means
that if you have a capital gain I hope
you do and in the in the situation and
God forbid and the way to cash it in you
get struck by lightning
you left your son or daughter they pay
nothing it was the tax own 12 seconds
earlier it's not an inheritance tax you
owed the tax 12 seconds earlier
you'll emanate that one you could put
every single solitary person qualified
in Community College in college and
creavy
increasing numbers six to nine million
people increasing the economic growth of
the country by two-tenths of one percent
and you'd have eleven billion dollars
left to reduce the deficit it's about
priorities if if you're in a town that
is a big town and you have children
childcare averages for two kids
twenty-four thousand bucks a year okay
that's after taxes if we gave everybody
in the United States America a single
mother or father a child a tax credit
for child care you would increase but
for $8,000 credit on your taxes you
would increase the number of women in
the workforce by 750,000 people because
they're making sound judgments guess
what
we increase the growth of GDP almost one
percent a year what are we doing what
are we doing the priorities were making
look let's think of how things have
changed not just for organized labor for
labor generally you know yeah forty
million people have to sign a
non-compete agreement when they go to
work
now that non-compete agreement makes
sense if you work for a tech company and
you have secrets or you you have an
agency you're gonna open one yourself
you sell it and you say I promise I
won't open one next door and compete
with it makes sense but the vast
majority those people are hourly workers
now if you're in fact you are in a
position what was the case you've worked
for Jimmy John's making sandwiches you
want to go across town to get five cents
more worker for McDonald's you can't do
it what possible reason for that big
xizt except to depress wages look what's
happened with corporate america where we
are now today corporate America folks it
used to be that they thought they had
more than one job created you know I
have a cartoon in my office from The New
Yorker magazine it's a picture of a
great big rotund guy sitting in an
interrogation table he has a black
turtleneck on a black mask and a black
beret and there's a and there's a big
bag on the table with a dollar sign on
it that's money he stole and he's
looking at interrogate he said I'm sorry
how was I supposed to know he was a job
creator well the job creators a day the
only people that are in fact get
benefits it used to be there needs to be
a basic bargain in American I'll end
with this if you participated in the
growth of the well-being of the
operation you worked with whatever it
was you got to share in the benefits got
to share the benefits that's doesn't
happen anymore that's not happening
anymore people weren't getting a share
of the rationale a guy named Milton
Friedman an economist came along said
the only obligation corporations have is
their stockholders they're the only job
creators well guess what how about all
those folks who work in a packing factor
how about all those folks who
back workers John Deere I put all those
[ __ ] aren't they Creighton jobs
they're creating jobs they're not the
help they're not the stockholders why
don't they get to benefit anymore we got
to start to reward not just wealth we
got a reward work got a reward more the
folks
there's a lot more I want to say to you
but I'm taking too much your time
already
and the bad news shoes I said I'll be
back because I'm gonna be doing this all
over this is a critical state Iowa is a
critical critical state and the fact of
the matter is I don't I see all these
polls they get given to me they don't
mean a thing right now this is a
marathon this is a marathon the marathon
is just beginning but at the end of the
day if you can't cross the line in Iowa
you don't win the marathon it's an
important deal so I'm gonna be back to
make my case to you ask you as I used to
say when I first ran my name is Jill
Biden I'm running for in this case
running for president on States look me
over if you like what you see help out
if not vote for the other person but
give me a look that's all I'm asking
thank you all
very
[Applause]
[Music]